i feel like we're at the end of cancel
culture so for some background before we
get into this cancel chaos there is an
award-winning chef online known as pippa
eats
i'm not aware of her before today her
name is pippa middlehurst she studied
east and southeast asian cuisine for
over 15 years she attended the lanzau
noodle school in 2019. i hope i'm
pronouncing that correct
which is famous for teaching students
how to hand pull noodles which i've had
these hand pulled noodles they're
amazing
she published her first cookbook on
dumplings and noodles back in august of
2020. rosalind talison is a culture
writer and contributor for the av club
[ __ ] media refinery refinery29 and vice
and she tweeted the following on august
15th why did a white woman write a
cookbook about dumplings and noodles
classic cancel culture dunk uh her tweet
caught a ton of blowback with most
people making fun of her ridiculous take
as you would expect pippa who had been
inactive on twitter for a year responded
in a quite reasonable way hi roslyn
trying to approach this without
defensiveness and it seems as though
your issue is with the larger system of
injustice in food publishing under
representation of
bipoc authors over representation of
white authors rather than me personally
i think so
anyway
attacking an individual she continues
that you know nothing about
pasting a picture of my face and calling
me an arrogant and uncreative white
woman allows others who respect your
opinion to justify harassing me in my
experience tweets like this don't
challenge a systematic issue or
instigate any other change it just
serves to temporarily make me the poster
child for that system of injustice that
no doubt i am part of that's an
interesting statement on her part she
didn't personally do anything i think is
what she's saying but because she's
white she's i guess saying she's part of
that system and simply leads to dog
piling and bounds of threatening dms
telling me
for example to go and drown in quotes
you deserve to fail in quotes and she
ended it there after pippa's response
talison claimed the mob had turned on
her and that she was being harassed by
nazis which she claims pippa had enticed
to defend her
then and here's rosalind's tweet the
nazi and white supremacist harassment
has been ongoing for about 24 hours by
the time she posted this she could have
looked at the replies or quotes on my
tweet she commented on but her feelings
were so hurt that she didn't care yada
yada now
before making her account private
talisman mentioned she was going to need
therapy after two days of harassment
from nazis and then she dropped her
personal paypal link for tip anyway
therapy costs 130 hours a session and
i'm going to need it after this 48 hours
harassment and she is asking for money
the entire situation is obviously a
crazy mess now why are we talking about
here on this week in startups i think
this culture is enabled specifically by
technology social media is the topic of
the show and i think this canceled
culture
there there are people who obviously
deserve to be canceled for being
horrible human beings
but i do think that when it comes to
discussions about things that are
delicate
if you're gonna dunk on somebody you
need to get to know them a little bit
and and maybe these conversations we
better had one-on-one or face-to-face
and this is coming for me i've thrown a
dunk or two on twitter i try to reserve
it for professor cold takes but the chad
i don't know who the chat is i mean this
is some sort of joke account i think had
a funny tweet that i think actually
speaks about this specific style of
cancelled culture he says tweets like
this make me think i should open a rehab
center for those addicted to twitter
clout it would have to be constructed
out of materials that block wi-fi and
cellular data
with day trips outside the city and
rehabilitation plans to help patients
experience offline life don't i know it
on july
12th or something or 14th i decided and
i pinned to my profile on twitter
twitter.com jason that i'm taking a
twitter break now i read twitter i'll
like things but i stopped engaging on
there you will see me post this podcast
and say hey the pods up you might see me
since i'm writing the book talk about my
progress in the book that's about it and
my i can tell you my head
is so clear on my vacation and my ideas
are flowing better so this is a psa
if you're on twitter or other social
networks getting wound up take a break
it is wonderful i am in month two of my
break
and i have recaptured
hours and hours of words and cognitive
cycles that i was wasting on twitter
sustained twitter addiction is a real
negative and it sends people into this
type of rabbit hole which results in
pain and suffering
you have two different people dunking on
each other and
one of them has a mob of nazis who are
going to defend her which she obviously
doesn't want the other one has a mob of
woke people trying to attack the other
person which i'm sure she doesn't want
the other person attacked neither of
them want to see each other suffer so
for the love of god can you just dm each
other and maybe just
maybe go out and have a meal together or
talk about your mutual love of
cooking dumplings and noodles maybe that
would actually be productive folks and
an account i gp and i'm not giving any
endorsement of these accounts by the way
or their positions i'm just informing
you of people's reactions so don't take
any of these things i'm reading as i
endorse it or i endorse the person i
don't know most of these people but
l-m-a-o laughing my ass off the woman
has been learning east southeast asian
cooking for over 15 years and attended
an actual effing noodle school in china
if you think it's impossible for anyone
who is in chinese to be just as first in
preparing dumplings as anywhere else in
the culture mike selena never one to not
jump into a bar fight said pretty good
noodle drama going on right now this is
interesting i want to show you a really
good example about how cultures can
influence each other in a positive way
not through appropriation but through
inspiration if you don't know my
favorite director after ridley scott is
akira kurosawa
and it's just a slight edge for ridley
scott because of
gladiator and blade runner but the
kurosawa high and low seven samurai
yojimbo these are some of the greatest
films ever made pure beauty like
watching a painting unfold before your
eyes highly recommend watching high and
low just incredible film noise by
kurosawa and yojimbo and seven samurai
and stray dog another nawah film from
kurosawa because kurosawa was inspired
by the friend noir detective stories so
the french inspiring kurosawa kurosawa
inspired george lucas
a lot of the characters and a lot of the
iconography in star wars comes from
kurosawa in fact darth vader if you can
envision in your mind the mask looks a
lot like samurai armor and headdresses
and in fact that's where he got it from
and obviously there are lightsabers and
samurai swords you get the idea in fact
in the hidden forest there are two
characters that he modeled r2d2 and c3p
c3po after who were like bumbling fools
i think there were guards if i remember
the story correct i think they caught i
think it was called hidden fortress so
let's just pause for a second here
kurosawa was a big inspiration to lucas
but i am super excited that
disney plus has charged six different
japanese animation studios to produce
nine short films in anime style of
star wars stories they're calling it
star wars visions
so let's take a moment
and look at how
cultural sharing and inspiration can
produce amazing products in the world
some people will like to focus on
tearing each other down for being
inspired
a white woman being inspired by chinese
noodles let's take a moment here and
just think
about how amazing it is that the french
directors inspired kurosawa kurosawa
inspired
lucas and now lucas is inspiring
japanese animators and anime this is
great and if you're watching this on
youtube you can see the trailer i cannot
wait to see this startup needs business
insurance and you should look no further
than a broker if you don't have
insurance you fail one of the first
steps in broker technology saves you
time and money prices are up to 20 lower
with better coverage than the incumbents
you can go from sign up to quote and
purchase in just 10 minutes when you
work within broker instead of business
insurance incumbents you're not dealing
with large slow corporations plus the
sign up takes days not weeks and the
process is transparent with no opaque
pricing
here are four crucial types of startup
insurance that they cover and you're
gonna need all four of these in all
likelihood cyber insurance in case you
get hacked dno insurance so your if your
directors and officers do something dumb
and you get sued you're covered you have
eno insurance which covers errors and
omissions that's what the e and the o
stands for and it helps you scale
because many major customers will ask to
see your eno insurance in order to close
a deal and of course epl employment
practices liability this covers
harassment wrongful termination and more
to instantly buy custom built insurance
for startups go to inbroker.com twist
that's
e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r dot com
slash twist and while you're there get
an extra 10 off using the offer code
twist you guessed it okay let's get back
to this amazing episode